we made a cheap pagi device that can
hack Wi-Fi networks in seconds firstly
we took a single board computer the
raspberry pi0w for $15 we plug it into
the power
supply then we plug the screen into the
connector on the board we also use the
small power bank to power up our pona
GOI finally we need a fast micro SD card
to put the operating system on it at a
minimum of 8 GB capacity when the
hardware is assembled we need to
download firmware from pagoti Project
website and write it to an SD card using
the bolina eter program once the
firmware has been written to the SD card
we access it on the computer open the
boot folder and create a configuration
file called config DOL and is almost
ready for hacking watch our big video to
see the
steps